the investigation at the blast site has
started in earnest
three days after the explosion the
cordoned off area near where the
ammonium nitrate was stored
is being scoured for clues or evidence
left behind
in this field of debris among the
investigators
bomb disposal specialists experienced in
identifying
and dealing with explosives the harbour
is also being searched
with teams of divers kitted out in scuba
diving equipment
making repeated trips the lebanese
government has given an investigative
committee
four days to determine responsibility
for this tragedy
but amidst the investigation there's
also an increasingly desperate search
for survivors
they've already located what appears to
be the start of an underground network
of panic rooms
built beneath the giant silo stores now
they're trying to shift the piles of
rubble and spilt grain laying on top
so they can investigate
they know that there's a labyrinth of
subterranean chambers here
they've discovered the opening of just
one of them
and if you come a bit closer you can see
the top of
what looks like the ceiling of one
and that's what is keeping the hopes of
relatives alive
that somehow their loved ones have made
it
to that shelter a turkish group with
experience in rescuing people after
earthquakes
isn't giving up yet we encountered like
these situations before
when you've actually pulled people out
after this length of time
yes so you're still holding on to hope
every time yeah social rescue is
every time have has hopes
human life is very important human life
is
over everything therefore every time we
have
thoughts but it's an agonizing weight
for the relatives of those still missing
who don't know whether they're alive or
dead
as rooty is head of the operations room
for the port silos
his wife and youngest daughter are keen
to show us photos of him
he told them never to worry about his
safety at the port
when the civil war was happening they
used to go
there and when there was explosions
blasts and everything they would hide
down there
so she thinks he knows how to handle
this
but his family and friends are furious
at the lack of government action
on all fronts 40 hours
it has been 40 hours before the
equipment and the machinery
went to the site where is my father so
we have hopes we still have hopes even
though it's getting diminished
by every second that they are late
and they are
they have no faith in the promises of a
government inquiry
and they're determined someone is held
to account for this
i'm gonna translate this anger into
something more effective and work harder
harder
each and every time to get justice
not just for my dad not just for the
missing people
but for all lebanon
so many families have been torn apart by
this tragedy
and so many feel utterly let down by
those in charge
alex crawford sky news beirut